bientôt monde c est bien sûr question
ultime épisode iso 9001 9
c'est bon tu annonces te maltraite mais
est ce que tes autres meubles en font
autant
non je veux passer quatre inc est une
farce à ton chat
[Musique]
tu places pour des films non parce que
j'ai ma petite fierté personnelle qui
dit que je ne dois pas pleurer plus
encore le film même si les super triste
ces jeux rien je me suis rendu compte
qu'on était tous les deux a tué son fils
montrent à l'interrompre comme quoi je
ne pleure pas c'est la route pas le cas
tu peux faire une petite démonstration
de breakdance bien évidemment y aller le
superpouvoir de ton chat le mât s'est
pas encore l'heure de manger tu préfères
quoi un peu de talent et un peu tu crées
16 novembre 3 bronze et insiste son
charme 1 et d'ailleurs c'est plutôt
énervant parce qu'à ce rythme là dans
deux mois elle ressemblera plus à ça mon
chat et ce ne sera plus mon cher
d'ailleurs est ce que tu es schizophrène
alors là comment ils peuvent croire des
choses pareilles assez clair jeu
politique des choses que tu emmènerait
sur une île déserte pour personne si on
reste ici en crèche vous propose donc
qu'on est tous sur cette île déserte et
vous avez vous le traitez minimum eau
nourriture mais c'est une autre musique
fine une démo de danse en duo avec ta
lampe
as c'est un honneur pour moi vraiment
j'espère un jour que ça sera la toile on
se bat le relais
combien tatouage du tsl je te laisse
conter non non c'est parce que tu crois
annie un petit tu te botter les fesses
et squeeze et à jour son tour pour un
twittos comment avoir un teint parfait
vous allez avoir besoin d'un visage donc
si tu t'es fait guillotiner n'ya pas
longtemps et là tu peux pas et la fonte
un gros cargo le mien je sais pas ce que
c'est la première étape c'est de bêtes
pleines dents
une fois qu'on est menacée dans ta main
comme là tu vas faire sont blondes
d'amarna grèce notamment été arrêtés je
suis pas je ne fais pas tout et voilà
vous avez maintenant temps par faire des
cookies d'imperfections merci serais tu
capable de faire un combat épique avec
talent sur la musique moscow vous avez
raison il faut que ça cesse
c'est bon j'vais tu es tu trouves pas
que tu ressembles à un rose bowl ha bah
merci beaucoup je le prends très très
bien parce qu'elle reprenne vraiment
beau gosse puis si tu dis ça c'est que
doit vraiment beaucoup lui ressembler un
ensemble un 2 0 pour celle très bien et
ben en fait sur maicon dont il est beau
gosse malcolm en plus d'ailleurs
quels sont tes meilleurs techniques de
drague alors moi j'ai une technique qui
marche vraiment presque à tous les coups
salut ça va oui mais si j'en rajoute sa
pudeur qui prévoit qu une rébellion
contre talent bleus en espérant que
celle-ci ne verra pas ce tweet
oh mon dieu elle est plus démoniaque que
jamais
[Applaudissements]